I love that sound Christmas Is Here
mulled wine is a real Christmas classic
but I'm going to give it a modern 21st
century twist
first pour red wine into a pan and
gently heat
now I'm gonna make a fragrant bouquet
garni basically a really nice aromatic
tea bag
muslin cloth absolutely perfect for this
if you haven't got muslin cloth a brand
new J cloth is just as good now first
off cardamom pods
they are incredibly aromatic and more
importantly gives a really nice dense
spicy flavor next add a pinch of clothes
clothes are dried flower buds and add a
lovely pungent sweet flavor
then dropping a couple of star anise
which adds an aniseed note a cinnamon
stick
cinnamon sticks are made from the bark
of trees native to Sri Lanka break one
in and this gives a warm sweet spice to
the wine
lemongrass so this makes it slightly
asiany a little bit more sort of
exciting but gives a really nice Light
twist to the wine all I'm going to do
first is just press down
on the lemongrass what that does it
starts to release all that oil and
flavor once it's crushed just cut it
over the muslin cloth
once all your spices are in fold up the
muslin cloth and tie tightly
and look
that
is like a little miniature perfect chest
pillow into the wine next add orange
zest twist
then cut the orange into wedges and pop
those in too
the sweeten the wine put in a tablespoon
of Demerara sugar
next stem Ginger gives them all wine a
little bit of a sort of kick almost like
a really nice sort of ginger beer
aftertaste on the back of your throat
finally a couple of tablespoons of the
ginger syrup and then simply heat the
wine gently for four to five minutes to
infuse all the Fantastic flavors but
don't let it boil or the alcohol will
evaporate
and together with that the most amazing
spice nuts
I love nuts so I'm using Brazil's
almonds walnuts
[Music]
and hazelnuts and then finally
pistachios lovely really nice festive
mix as the nuts toast they start to
release their natural oils then add a
couple of pinches of salt
and then just let them lightly toast
once the nuts start to color add half a
teaspoon of cayenne pepper which is made
from ground chilies
then sprinkle in half a teaspoon of
paprika a milder Spice made from dried
pimentos for sweetness and depth
[Music]
see
the nuts
absorbing all that wonderful flavor
mixing delicious finally put in a sprig
of rosemary give the pan a good toss to
make sure all the nuts are thoroughly
coated and they're done
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
the best way to make cooking easier and
less stressful on Christmas Day is to
get organized and prepare as much as
possible in advance leaving you more
time to spend with your family
making a stunning pork apricot and
pistachio stuffing the day before is a
great way to get ahead it's easy to do
looks a million dollars and tastes
absolutely delicious
Christmas dinner for me is not about
food piled high on a plate less is more
I'd rather have five or six things on a
plate that tastes absolutely delicious
than 10 items tasting average stuffing
for instance
I'd much rather put a lot more effort
into the stuffing and enjoy it but eat a
lot less of it first add pork mince to
the bowl season with salt and pepper and
mix take your grater and a braver an
apple just get the grater
and Grate the Apple in there
usually stuffing is cooked in the turkey
but I'm doing mine separately so I can
make in advance and get the flavor and
presentation spot on
now the nice thing about the Apple it
goes brilliant well with the pork makes
it a little bit sweeter
it also makes it a lot lighter as well
which is really important next add a
handful of chopped apricots which gives
the stuffing another fruity note and a
lovely texture the Apple disintegrates
but the apricots stay really nice and
intact
nice little bite
then chop a handful of pistachio nuts
again
I'm thinking of the build up of textures
flavor
and also color
pistachios in
now give that a really good mix
grating some lemon zest the zest is
packed full of intensely flavored
essential oils which gives the stuffing
a vibrant Citrus zing
[Music]
and for freshness add a handful of
coarsely chopped parsley
the balance of flavors
is nice and delicate and it sits
beautifully with a turkey now sage and
pork and apple that's the perfect
marriage now I'm going to think about
the presentation skills tinfall
a little drizzle of olive oil
and then
we got a real nice
fragrant Sage leaves
the sage leaves are used to wrap the
stuffing start by overlapping them
it's almost like rolling a cigar but
we're going to roll it in Sage leaves
taste this Paramount but presentation is
really important too so it's worth
spending a few extra minutes to get this
right because it will make the final
dish look amazing
now a little season
across the top
[Music]
and then take your sausage meat
I don't want to do now I'm just put half
it
onto the plate
[Music]
I just want to run your finger along the
stuffing
this is where it takes on a completely
different flavor again I need some spice
in there I want a little bit of heat in
the stuffing so it's exciting to eat
it's mergys merga is our traditional
North African sausages made from beef or
lamb and all we're going to do now
let's take the sausage and lay that
in the middle they're flavored with
Harissa afari chili paste which gives
them the Heat and distinctive color it
really does give that nice sort of wake
up call inside the stuffing
if you can't get hold of mergys other
spicy sausages like chorizo would work
well too take the rest of the stuffing
and we'll sit there on top
so in cases
that mergys
[Music]
once you've got it like that lift up the
twin full
very carefully
and roll that over
that the temple do the work roll it nice
and tight
there
fingers underneath
[Music]
just pull that back and double check
lovely
look at it it's not even cooked yet and
it looks delicious
The Ultimate Christmas cracker fantastic
that Sage will cook and really perfume
the sausage meat and you cut through to
the scent you've got that nice spicy
sausage lovely
in
now roll it
across twist at the ends
and then from there up into the hands
and you push it in and twist and turn
and all that's doing
is just making the perfect cylinder
beautiful the stuffing can be made
wrapped and stored in the fridge a day
or two in advance
that's the first part of my Ultimate
Christmas dinner ready on Christmas Day
simply pop it into the oven and cook at
200 degrees for 40 minutes
[Music]
foreign
cranberry and apple sauce is another
recipe I always cook a day in advance
it packs a wonderful punch that really
lifts the subtle flavor of the turkey
it's simple to make and with its deep
red vibrant color looks fantastic on the
plate
I think you're behind any good Christmas
is in the organization and the
preparation anything can get done in
advance do it apple and cranberry sauce
is a prime example first things first
we're gonna make a really nice caramel
sugar in at 150 grams of caster sugar to
a pan
followed by a couple of star anise that
helps to really give
a nice sort of aniseed flavor to The
Cranberries next lightly crushed four
cardamom pods this has a lovely warm
Spicy Sweet flavor
then wait for the sugar to melt and form
a caramel really important to have the
confidence now to color that caramel so
it goes really nice and dark before
putting the Cranberries in
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
acidic but balanced with the sweetness
of the caramel and apples they give the
sauce a lovely dry sharp note to tell if
they're fresh drop them on a hard
service the higher they bounce the
fresher they are
the cigar now is for the caramel to
blister the cranberries and really start
to break that down
smells fantastic next core peel and
thinly sliced two apples and once the
sauce is finished it really does help to
sort of wake up
the flavor of the turkey Now The
Cranberries are starting to break down
Apple in
smells fantastic
a touch of salt and pepper
really important really helps to balance
that tartness against the acidity of the
Apple salt and pepper really brings it
back
[Music]
the smell is fantastic it's not a sort
of sweet sour spicy nice
now from there
delays the pan with a touch of port
around the side
deglazing dissolves all the lovely
sticky caramelized bits of food that are
stuck to the pan and incorporates them
into the sauce
next add the zest of an orange
and for another layer of fragrance
sweetness squeezing the juice
lovely then cook on a low heat for five
to ten minutes to thicken but remember
the salt will become even thicker once
it's cooled down now that
is the right texture I don't want a
runny sauce I want something really nice
and thick delicious packed full of
flavor
perfect
really want to get ahead this sauce can
be made three or four days in advance
and kept in the fridge which allows the
flavors to develop even more
[Music]
Christmas Day simply bring it up to room
temperature and serve another job done
leave any more time to enjoy this very
special day
[Music]
first I'm getting mum to help cook my
chili and turmeric roasted potatoes this
dish is another Twist on tradition it
gives the potatoes a lovely color and
their spicy kick helps complement and
lift the whole Christmas meal
we're just gonna do again a little twist
the potatoes
goose fat so we're gonna do a really
nice
um lightly spiced
roast potato okay A little chili flake
chili yeah chili flake just put a little
bit of heat in there for the Christmas
lunch yep chili flake and a little bit
of turmeric
I can't believe you're doing roast
potatoes for chili
now would you be so kind just to give
them a little cut the peeled potatoes
into quarters and put into salted cold
water in they go
okay bring them up to the boil and
simmer for around eight minutes
drain and let them steam then season
with salt and pepper on there and just a
little teaspoon of chili flake oh no
that's the sort of thing I would make
for supper and a Saturday night or
something like that you know really
chili flakes in add a teaspoon of
turmeric turmeric is a member of the
ginger family it stains the potatoes a
wonderful golden color and has a lovely
earthy taste
next drizzle in a little olive oil and
Shake to coat them just let them all
around yeah
that smells nice beautiful could you get
me the stuffing please from the fridge
put in a preheated baking tray with
extra olive oil and cook at 200 degrees
Celsius for about 40 minutes give a
little shake to make sure they don't
stick
and then I'll just stick the stuffing
thank you man
on top here
now that will take roughly about the
same time as potatoes stuffing in
potatoes done nice why are you going to
play with the kids I will do yeah okay
see you shortly thank you bye-bye
Christmas dinner wouldn't be complete
without brussels sprouts but when I was
a child they were boiled until horribly
soft
I want to keep my Sprouts crisp vibrant
and fresh sauteed with pancetta and
chestnuts these are sprouts like you've
never tasted before
and Brussels sprouts are delicious when
they cook perfectly packed with texture
and the flavor is extraordinary
take off the outer leaves trim the
bottom and cut in half as a big step up
from the crisscross on the bottom that
my mother used to do every Christmas I'm
cutting them in half so when I so do
them they cook evenly and look
it's like little baby cabbages it's so
compact
then blanch them in salted boiling water
for two minutes
[Music]
now
this is the most amazing pancetta
lightly cured
pancetta is a type of Italian bacon
which is brilliant for adding a lovely
Rich meaty flavor to dishes I want a
really nice robust flavor
to go with that earthy texture
of the Sprout
it's made from pork belly and is dry
cured with salt and aromatics like
Juniper bay leaves nutmeg dry Thyme and
garlic as it hits the pan that fats on
top of the pancetta melts and gives the
Sprouts this amazing flavor after
removing the skin cut into small chunks
can't get hold of pancetta Smoke's
tricky bacon is a good alternative now
hot pan
teaspoon of olive oil
give it a like seasoning with salt and
pepper
as a lathers start to crisp up
take your Sprouts out
drain them
[Music]
Sprouts in
now give that a really nice little toss
then chop up a handful of chestnuts now
the chest does sweetened the flavor
of the Sprout
really important that you don't put the
chestnuts in too early otherwise they'll
go mush
and then just sprinkle
the
chestnuts
over
lovely
so we've managed to turn a sort of plain
Jane Sprouts into something quite
delicious you've got the texture of the
smoked bacon the sauteed Sprout and that
nice Crunch and sweetness of a festive
Chestnut
10 seconds before they come out lemon
zest
over
now that makes the sprouts and the bacon
harmonize
and then just to squeeze
of fresh lemon juice over the sprouts
beautiful
this right now is the ultimate
and for me that's a really nice modern
21st century approach
to cook in an old-fashioned vegetable
s done I'm ready to serve my Ultimate
Christmas dinner
cooked and rested
take the turmeric and chili roasted
potatoes from the oven now they look and
smell Fantastic look at that beautiful
slice the pork apricot and pistachio
stuffing
[Music]
as the gravy reheats crush the walnuts
it's really nice combination crushed
walnuts with a turkey gravy
sprinkling the gravy boat and it's ready
to serve stuffing gravy and cranberry
[Music]